is perhaps the toughest sanction the
west has levied against russia around 70
of its banks and financial institutions
have been cut off from swift the system
used by banks to send money across
borders it is a move that's impact
reaches well beyond russia itself many
banks in the u.s the eu and the uk have
given loans to russian firms who can now
no longer service them it's unclear
exactly how much banks have loaned to
russian companies but the experts are
putting this number somewhere in the
tens of billions of euros then there is
of course the potential for sovereign
debt default russia's central bank can't
access its assets abroad and is on
course to miss repayments to its
creditors now russia currently owes
nearly 50 billion dollars to lenders in
the west payments are due within the
next two weeks one for 100 million
dollars in interest another of over 2
billion
among the countries levying sanctions on
russia is switzerland it's an
unprecedented step for the financial hub
that prides itself on staying neutral
but it's still being urged to take
further action
zurich is one of the world's most
expensive places and that's in no small
part due to russian oligarchs happy to
invest their money here
rudolph elma used to be a top banker at
the venerable zurich bank yulia spare
today he is a critic of these financial
institutions who came to international
prominence as a wikileaks whistleblower
in this rightful field
a lot of money is invested in
switzerland because banking secrecy
protects the oligarchs we have a strict
secrecy law
the government politicians and the
judiciary support this because it is a
huge source of income for the swiss
state
russia's brutal war against ukraine has
put worldwide pressure on switzerland to
respond it's likely one of the reasons
why the government here has backed the
sanctions saying russian oligarchs
should no longer be able to access their
assets here but elmer is skeptical
switzerland was slow to introduce
sanctions and that gave the oligarchs
plenty of time to shift their fortune
somewhere else
concealing the origin of money is a long
tradition in switzerland
this means that the actual owner is
disguised via trusts in the cayman
islands or companies or whatever in such
a way that you don't really know who's
behind
it the swiss bankers association rejects
this accusation saying the sanctions
would be strictly observed
it's important to understand that these
sanctions oblige banks to report russian
customers to the authorities banking
secrecy is never absolute
it can be affected by a legal obligation
to provide information and that is also
the case with these sanctions
this is concrete
sanctions
gazprom bank and spare bank seen here in
zurich are exempt from the sanctions
that allows eu countries like germany to
still be able to buy russian oil and gas
through them but public criticism is
growing spare bank in zurich has covered
over its logo and lowered window blinds
for fear of protests
the swiss ngo public eye has long
criticized the russian banks and now it
says they're playing a critical role in
moscow's war
this is of course a substantial part of
vladimir putin's war chest he calculated
it that way from the start
and also anticipated that this money at
least would continue to flow
we're talking about a billion dollars a
day eighty percent of which comes from
swiss commodities trading platforms
one of the data centers for the swift
bank payment system is very close to
zurich it's currently under heavy guard
for fear of russian sabotage but elmer
doesn't think a complete russian cutoff
from swift would be that dramatic for
russia
there are various ways of getting around
this like inter-company deals
banks holding bank accounts at other
banks
and trade shortcuts as well as barter
transactions
there are many variants and you have to
see that this payment transaction
business has become even more lucrative
today due to the sanctions
rudolf elmer now lives in seclusion near
zurich but he hasn't stopped criticizing
switzerland's financial institutions and
authorities he's demanding strict laws
for better monitoring of the financial
centre but so far says he's seen no
willingness in the government to take
action
well i've been speaking to jurg rockhole
who's president of the european school
of management and technology esmt berlin
i asked him how surprising it was that
switzerland had joined the eu in
sanctioning russia
the
fact that switzerland joined is
certainly just representing the overall
observation that we have at this point
of time
that uh there is such a strong
unified approach across western
countries that no one could escape and
in particular we've seen in the past
that any bank that tries to escape
or say circumvent sanctions has been
penalized heavily by in particular u.s
authorities so therefore it might be a
little bit surprising but in light of
the overall development and also in
light of what we've seen as a penalties
in the past it's maybe not that
surprising
is it a big blow to the russian banking
system to have these sanctions from
switzerland in particular given the role
that it it plays with its much stricter
secrecy laws
this is certainly a blow to russian
banks but maybe it's even more a blow
in the asset management part so this
means
if wealthy russians
put their money to switzerland now um
they are sanctioned as well swiss banks
are extremely careful in now um
operating on the level uh actually with
any russian client and thus it becomes
also more difficult to withdraw private
money from switzerland and use it for
other purposes
is this the sort of change that
could last for a long time what what's
what's the feeling with these sanctions
that they're going to be in place
forever and russians are permanently
going to have to find a new way to move
their money around and indeed move their
their exports
um i see two elements here for sure i
would expect the sanctions to be in
place for the foreseeable future
but there's another aspect and maybe
this aspect might become even more
important so in the long run which is
the voting by feed mechanism that we see
now we have seen that many western
companies even companies that were not
restricted to do so by the sanctions
that they have actually started
withdrawing their business from russia
that also western companies don't want
to work anymore which would say russian
subsidiaries in europe in the united
states and this voting by feed has taken
really a very massive a very strong
movement over the last two weeks and
this is something that in my view has
not seen the end yet but rather will
continue and then it will be very hard
to revert these decisions in particular
as we see now if the russian government
even wants to nationalize to expropriate
the assets that western companies have
left in russia
yeah it's a major change for russia that
keeps
getting worse it keeps getting more and
more isolated from the rest of the world
and
indeed
it's looking less and less likely that
russia's going to be able to pay its
debts to its foreign creditors default
looks or almost certain doesn't it
yes indeed the rating agencies have now
made very clear
statements that russian sovereign debt
just is at a junk status
it's also not clear anymore whether even
if russia did have the money
whether they would be even willing to
pay so that they basically voluntarily
declare default this is why
basically
even more of the linkages of the
international financial systems to
russia will be stopped
and it will even isolate russia more in
many different ways and the financial
system is certainly at the forefront of
this first wave of sanctions
you